is just uh what was like a week ago we
got swatted and as Luke was discussing
post-pandemic civil unrest police
officer walks in and I'm sitting here
and I see the door open I see this cop
just walk past and I'm like what's going
on there's cops in outside the room
another cop fans me over and I'm like
wait were you nuts like we're sitting
here live got tens of thousands of
people and I wondered for a second if we
were being rated like project Veritas
had been like the police had come here
to execute some kind of Warrant I had no
idea my first thought was like okay they
they came here exactly when we were
doing the show on purpose knowing that
we were in a difficult position and now
they're going to use this because I'm
unavailable to basically run strategy
and all there's there's basically people
here security and they're not going to
know what to do in the face of this and
sure enough the police in my opinion
lied about exigent circumstances to
enter the property and do that check we
had been swatted there was claims of an
active shooter but once the police got
here they even say on on their radio so
they think it's a swatting incident and
they were told explicitly not to come in
they came in anyway as it turns out we
were not being right or anything but uh
James O'Keefe and project Veritas were
rated and joining us to actually talk
about the modern state of Journalism is
not just James O'Keefe but also Andino
and Libby Emmons so this should be a
pretty insane conversation of course
Lucas here Ian has the night off James
do you want to introduce yourself for
those that are not familiar with your
work Tim my name is James O'Keefe
founder of project Veritas uh author of
a new book called American muckraker out
a week from today so um thank you for
having me back thanks for coming man we
appreciate it we got Andy welcome Andy
hi Tim uh it's an honor to be here in
person finally uh I am a American
Independent journalist who writes about
antifa have a book out called unmasked
salt and paperback now in updated uh new
chapter right on and of course uh
everybody who's standing behind Andy can
be seen on camera you guys know just so
you guys know and then we have Libby
Evans so the post millennial hey
everyone I'm Libby Emmons I'm the
editor-in-chief with the post-millennial
and of course lucrutkowski if we are
changed hey guys you know the media is
pretty bad I would say just as bad to
the point where some people are making
t-shirts comparing the media to the
virus I can't believe some people are
doing that but if if you're interested
in maybe some of those shirts and
supporting we are change you can go to
thebestpoliticalshorts.com because you
do I'm here thank you so much for having
me this should be a great conversation
and I'm pretty sure that I think almost
everyone in here will be in the gulags
in just a few years so welcome comrades
thanks for coming indeed I am also here
in the corner pushing buttons I'm trying
to do the sound and the cameras as you
can tell I'm not doing the best job but
I'm excited to have these lovely people
here I'm stoked for tonight before we
get started head over to timcast.com
become a member because we're going to
have a special uncensored members only
podcast with everybody coming up around
we post at around 11 or so p.m so go to
timcast.com become a member help support
the work we do support the show and all
the journalists that we have on staff it
is because of your membership we're able
to keep doing this work so we appreciate
it don't forget like the like like this
video smash the like button I was like
what's the word I'm like smash so smash
the Subscribe Button as well share this
show with all your friends tell them we
are going to be having a um well I gotta
keep it family friendly I'll say
something else we are all going to have
a confirm confirmation by a session
ragging on the media yes and so we're
really excited that you're here and
let's just uh let's just get started
we'll talk with uh about the modern
state of Journalism of course most of
you know we hosted Marjorie Taylor green
within not even 24 hours we were swatted
it then we hosted I think just just like
the next show I think after that was
micro and we were slammed by a DDOS
attack which exceeded a gigabit which
for those aren't familiar I'm actually
fairly surprised that was able to happen
it was like a several gigabit
International botnet that attacked us
and so the work we do just on a talk
show is it's dangerous especially for
the establishment for powerful interests
and of course the work that all of you
guys do is extremely dangerous and thus
let's just talk about what happened with
you James you have a development on the
FBI raid on your headquarters and you
that's right uh well the federal judge
in New York and thank you again for
having me um
a lot has happened until I saw you by
the way yeah
you got swap people I get raided by the
FBI and
um and I'm proud to sit next here next
to my friend Andy no Andy is featured in
the first chapter of this book which the
first chapter is called suffering it's
called Suffering The Book American
muckrigger yes he he's been through some
physical violence
um I've been through a different type of
violence directed at us from the state
um 10 to 12 FBI agents showed up at my
house in November and took my phones
um and we'll talk more about that here
but
um and they did that not despite the
fact that we're doing journalists but
because we're doing Journal journalism
and that's how far it's gotten so
um a federal judge in New York the
southern district of New York also known
as The Sovereign District of New York
because they're quite autonomous with
their decision-making uh ordered the FBI
to stop doing that and then order what's
called a special Master to oversee the
FBI which is very rare you can count on
one hand how often that happened is the
federal judge citing journalistic
privilege Tim and this federal judge was
not a trump appoint it was an Obama
appointed federal judge and that what
was amazing to me when that happened was
that the ACLU defended us the reporters
Community defended us the society
professional journalist defended us
which showed me there still is this very
narrow consensus in this country between
left and right
um so this today uh we filed a motion
that the U.S attorneys argued that we
should pay for this special amount I
think we have some wind coming in yeah
you can hear it whistling whistling
maybe that's a sign yeah the ominous
wind right as we've been talking about
ominous wind in the background that's
what that was the soundtrack of our life
oh gosh um so the U.S attorneys bottom
line is the U.S attorneys argued before
the judge and before they assigned the
special Master the U.S attorney said
well your honor James O'Keefe is not a
journalist judge asked why and the U.S
attorneys the prosecutors said well your
honor James O'Keefe does not get
permission consent from the people that
he reports on it's non-consensual
reporting and recording what the hell
which is such a wrap right that's like a
two plus two equals five but this is
what they wrote in the motion the judge
rejected that argument thank God there
still is some sanity in New York and and
appointed this this special Master but
now the US attorneys are saying we
should pay the journalists should pay
the government this is extraordinary we
should just let uh the people of America
know that at the New York Times before
they cover any story about say James
they call them and get permission first
or before they release you know Donald
Trump's tax records or his personal
information they of course get consent
from the people that they're reporting
on all the time you know it's standard
protocol and definitely before someone
gets doxed like when the New York Times
uh tried to dox Tucker Carlson they of
course got permission first or when CNN
goes after grandmas who are posting on
Facebook right you know yeah they
definitely get permission from those
Grandmas so this is an extraordinary
this is an extraordinary I guess Rubicon
that we've not crossed yet now they're
starting to put people in handcuffs for
doing stories they don't want done right
yeah it's not enough to just censor the
stories on social media
now they want to come after people for
actually just doing the stories in the
first place I wonder what would have
happened
um to the New York Post if these kinds
of rules were in place last year well
and then the New York Times and you did
you did a few shows on this since I last
saw you the New York Times published my
attorney-client privileged documents
we could talk we do a whole show on that
but what's fascinating is that the New
York Times actually did an article
saying it's a crime to transport stolen
documents across state lines well I
guess that's actually what a lot of
those things the New York Times says
it's a crime to transport Stone which
means that every report of the New York
Times should be in jail yeah because
that's especially they're reporting the
dead on you and I mean maybe they should
be rated by the FBI for publishing my
attorney-client privileged documents but
but look at where the New York Times has
gone they've lit they they're not
adversarial journalists when they say
that stuff it's because they're the mask
is off the New York Times is a
mouthpiece of the state or or of some
kind of establishment elitists power
they have a symbiotic relationship with
the FBI and Pfizer and that's ironic
isn't it we who was it who was on who
was saying that the New York Times badia
Unger Sagan that the New York Times has
effectively just decided Their audience
is the upscale upper class Urban liberal
and they don't care about anybody else
anymore so that's just what they're
going to Pander to I think that's
exactly right you can see in the way
that their stories are written that
that's what they're trying to do I mean
if you read their stories in an NPR
voice it's exactly the same as listening
to NPR right
well there's a lot to say I mean I could
talk for an hour about this but there's
a lot to unpack here well so what's a
special so so let's start from the
beginning you were uh investigating uh
was it a story about Biden's daughter
Ashley Biden's diary a source and by the
way most people don't know that Ashley
Biden has a daughter named Ashley
um and there was a diary Joe Biden has a
daughter named sorry Joe Biden has a
daughter named Ashley and some a source
sent us this this document this diary
um and uh we looked into it I made the
decision not to publish it because I
couldn't verify with 100 certainty that
it was hers I was like 99 or whatever
percent but I wasn't 100 and even if I
could verify that it was Ashley Biden's
diary I couldn't verify what she wrote
in the diary happened she talked about
having inappropriate showers with her
dad whoa does that mean that she's wow
what does that mean and I felt like you
know and by the way this is this is the
crazy part about this Twilight Zone
dystopian series of events someone sends
me something I try to corroborate it I'm
unable to and I say well let me try to
give this back to her she wouldn't take
it so I give it to law enforcement what
more could a responsible ethical
journalist let alone human being do and
that's the scary part what ought I have
done yeah what should I have done but
then they raid me and then people come
to my home at 6am I'm not a morning
person my first thought when they
open up my first thought was sorry to
bang on it
I'm a show person is how much time do I
have until they break the door down and
I'm I'm waking up I'm pounding I'm
waking up and I'm thinking okay let me
run to the door like in my underwear and
then I go to open and then before I turn
the door I was like are they going to
shoot me how do I do this in a way where
I don't get killed and I open the door
and there's all these bright lights and
they put me in handcuffs were you in
your underwear yes I mean I just woken
up yeah and and then they throw me
against the hallway wall outside my
apartment my neighbors are I mean this
is I think I'm under arrest but for what
what have I done they actually arrest
you and take you they put me in
handcuffs and at and then eventually
they showed me a search warrant wow on
the search warrant it listed
I'm not making this [ __ ] up accessory
after the fact
and Miss prison of a felony accessory
after the fact these are these are they
haven't been charged with anything but
these are absurd insinuations of a crime
again if it's a crime to be sent a
document which may or may not be stolen
then you might as well jail all the
journalists in America so there was a
theory James what was happening here I
mean obviously you made the Right Moves
you went to the authorities you weren't
sure so you didn't publish you did
everything right here but they still
decided to raid you and and people are
theorizing that they did this because
there could have been federal agents
that were the ones that originally sent
you this diary to kind of set you up to
get an excuse to get into your
electronic devices because they knew
potentially someone else was reaching
out to you for a bigger story that they
needed to stop that's one of the
theories out there do you think that's
true because every step of the way here
the feds acted incorrectly
I don't want to speculate I don't want
to that is a theory is it a pretext is
it a form of intimidation I mean even
the New York Times Reporter Mike Schmidt
was like stumbling and bumbling and
fumbling on MSNBC when asked what have
they really raid the home if it wasn't
actually by a diary
a diary well so it's just it's just so
crazy there's no answers does that
authenticate the Diary of them
I would I would think so and that then
implicates uh
well then you've got witness
corroboration if the diary is true about
inappropriate behaviors with children
from President Joe Biden it wouldn't be
the first time there have been these
insinuations I've seen the videos either
the persistent sniffing uh James I do
want to say that I think you made the
right decision in passing up on uh the
contents of the Diary when you were
originally in possession of it what I
tell young journalists and new
journalists is that if you cannot a
hundred percent verify
something you don't report it out
correct even on even on that one percent
of doubt and that means often you miss
out on Scoops that end up being accurate
that other people pick up and it's
unfortunate and it's disappointing when
it happens but
um I I wish the New York Times had your
standards CNN and MSNBC because they'll
just say like you know Source says I I
love when they'll say like a source
close to Donald Trump's you know
familiar with the matter people familiar
with Trump's thinking have said he is he
wants to beat children or something
insane the New York Times Andy New York
Times did a story about the they
published the attorney-client memos and
a judge in New York has has done the
extraordinary Act of telling them to
sequester those attorney-client memos
and the New York Times wrote a headline
that said documents show how far
reporting practices could go before
running a foul of federal laws do you
know another way to say that we check
with lawyers to make sure everything
we're doing was legal but do you see how
they worded it they it's not so much
that they lie it's that they use this
sort of you have to like twist the
newspaper article a little bit to know
what they're saying they don't say
what's false they omit and so so that
that statement's true right but it's
framing it's framing it in a very it
sounds like we we skirted the law and
that's the scariest part about this
whole ordeal because it was a little
terrifying is that what was I supposed
to do
you think do I hindsight right what more
could we have done we even called we
even contacted the Biden campaign and
tried to ask for comment but the New
York Times framed that as leverage we
tried to Leverage The dire and then
Rachel Maddow said we tried to extort
the president so a request for comment
becomes leverage becomes extortion you
see how the game is played and and it's
very terrifying at times I I will I will
say too not not to derail too much but
uh you know CNN's ratings are down 90
they're in the key demo they barely get
viewers at all it's probably just hotel
lobbies so I don't know if that's any
consolation it's probably not but when
Rachel Maddow talks and and these
stories break I don't know if it's going
to matter in five or ten years because
they're losing
yes but when you have a dying animal
they usually act the most violent right
before they die well and that's what
they're doing they're giving up all of
their standards yes and then when we
look at you know the state it isn't in
in a place that's extremely vulnerable
the official story the official
narrative that they told us for two
years now is breaking shattering right
in front of our face and then people are
realizing hey we were lied to throughout
recorded human history whenever there's
pandemics usually it leads to civil
unrest so there's a big probability that
this is going to happen here and I think
they're trying to hit the mall with the
hammer as much as they can there's a lot
of moles popping up but I think there's
there's uh a lot of anger by this within
minutes the handcuffs were still my
wrists were still sore within minutes of
this happening I got a text message from
Mike Schmidt at the New York Times
National Security reporter how the hell
does he know the contents of a secret
grand jury subpoena and why the hell are
they leading me to the execution chamber
I am on the same team as these people we
are supposed to be speaking without fear
or faith favor which is the quote from
Adolf ox or whatever his name was the
founder of the New York Times I'll just
I'll just mention project Veritas had
one of the most important uh bits of uh
one of the most important stories
probably by generation the ABC Amy
roebach story with Epstein which
contributed to this major uh
investigation which ultimately I think
the Maxwell case is kind of being
covered up we can get into that stuff
but uh Veritas that's not partisan when
you report on the story saying this is a
a journalist saying I had the interview
I had the story and it didn't get out
that was exposing powerful establishment
Elites covering up a very serious
Scandal as an understatement that's
right but why is the New York Times
going after you
is it you know it's not it's not just
the New York Times I mean it is it is
all of these news outlets that falsely
frame everything about Veritas in an
effort to harm you when uh you're doing
stories about you know powerful
corporations and it's also journalists
should be on your side and it's also all
the social media companies right I have
come after you and they recently pulled
one of your employees off as well Eric's
standing in the room exactly although I
will say and I want Andy to get in here
but we've trended on Twitter almost
every story we've done but that story we
did last week on the Pentagon papers
Department of Defense documents which
effectively are Pentagon Papers trended
number one on Twitter I'm banned on
Twitter project Veritas is banned on
Twitter but what do you think well it's
it's not a side detail that uh an agent
of the State uh is working with media
organizations
um to
be the first to break these stories that
are extremely damaging where you know
you don't have to be charged with any
crimes it's the investigation and the
reporting and media coverage on it that
destroys reputations and what happened
to James here with how while uh he still
have mocks on his hand from the
handcuffs like he's getting requests
from the press for comment when nobody
else knows about it obviously agents of
the state is working with the
journalists and leaking information
similarly when when Roger Stone was
arrested and CNN had been tipped off
with the helicopter I think I just I'll
just say you know when you look at
despotic regimes in tin pot uh uh
democracies like these are like
characteristics of it
I mean this is disturbing and I I don't
I I it surprises me that so much in the
American public just kind of shrugged
their shoulders and you know praise
these uh media organizations and when I
I mean I'm thinking right now you know
with with the the the States you know
colluding with these these these big
media companies to cover up malfeasance
and Corruption it it's it sounds
fascistic and I just wish there was
maybe some organization maybe that was
called like something opposed to Fascism
like like no fascism or maybe
anti-anti-fascism we call it antifa for
sure and they would stand up to this
kind of collusion between State and
massive powerful private Enterprise yeah
where's that at where where is the
actual and I know obviously duh we don't
antifess but I'm like where's the actual
opposition from from activists to say
you know this is a bad thing now that
being said I will stress James you did
get defended by some of these
institutions like the ACLU did because
they crossed the line so far yeah even
the ACLU was like well I guess we have
to say something one of the things that
the I hate to put it in Left Right terms
because increasingly this seems to be
about good versus evil and I don't
necessarily think those lines are clear
but the left tends to overplay their
hand they tend to take it too far and it
ends up biting them in the ass that was
a beautiful moment when Ben Smith at the
New York Times And if Ben is watching
this Ben Smith media columnist New York
Times defended me he was the first
person this was a few days afterwards
and he says journalists should not be
cheerleading this if you look at that
tweet he got ratioed hardcore no put
that O'Keefe in jail they don't care
they just want to jail jail there and I
know people who say lock her up and all
that like I feel like are we so
manichaean that we need to jail people
who disagree with us no but Ben defended
me and after Ben did he gave all these
other people the permission to do so
ACLU Society you know all these
organizations
um and by the way Ben Smith is leaving
the New York Times why is he doing that
great question and we can I can also
report to you that there's kind of a
Schism inside the New York Times well
it's not the first time I mean the the
major Schism happened when Tom Cotton's
op-ed ran and it destroyed the op-ed
section of the New York Times Barry
Weiss left that's right the whole
Newsroom got shaken up
um that was an insane thing that
happened that Tom Cotton saying that the
federal government should intervene in
cities and deal with the civil unrest
that was happening
um it broke the New York Times it broke
the New York Times and the editorial
page editor whose Name Escapes me uh uh
when we released on the deposition tape
James Bennett I have a posse I have my
Entourage here we always travel with an
Entourage project Paradise uh James
Bennett was actually a pretty moderate
guy yeah he wasn't yeah and they made
him out to be a devil so I can report to
you because I have sources
well people I've covertly recorded I
haven't released yet
who've told me there is a Schism there
but Tim that was a beautiful moment in
in my life watching people who hate us I
think there still is some principle
there still is some overlap between the
left and right in our society they're
they're I think there's there it's
probably a bit reductive or um maybe
simplistic but there's two big camps
when it comes to whatever's going out
the establishment people who are
willfully lying and manipulative for
power and people who are blindly going
along and maybe just scared so there's
probably a lot of people who saw what
happened with the New York Times and Tom
Cotton's op-ed and they're like I just
want to get through this the problem I
have with these people it was uh Clifton
Duncan tweeted something I'm probably
gonna screw it up but he said that he's
less concerned about those that are
overtly engaged in malfeasance and evil
and he's more concerned about those who
know what's going on but won't speak up
I saw that too I thought that was really
fascinating and made a lot of sense
that's right well the New York Times are
also being kind of eaten up by hedge
funds and the people who truly own them
I think this is why Jeff Bezos bought
the Washington uh times because
Washington Post excuse me uh because
people are understanding this this quote
by Lord northcliffe when he said quote
news is what somebody somewhere wants to
suppress all the rest is advertising
these people are buying advertising
they're buying PR they're buying favors
for themselves literally trying to
brainwash the American public so their
agenda their narrative will pass and
clear no matter how absurd they still
push these ideas because these ideas are
way more important than even the money
that they put into these institutions
that they're losing what's so
fascinating about that though is so
we're at the post-millennial we you know
I kind of think of us as the antidote to
fear right we're not corporate uh we're
a small Outlet you know Andy and I run
stories there all the time
um and what's really interesting is that
we're getting attacked you know we get
attacked by these activists who are
saying that we are aligned with specific
interests and we're not they're
defending the big Outlets the big
corporate media Outlets that are aligned
with specific interests and here we are
just like you know covering news stories
covering what we think is interesting
trying to get the truth out there and
they attack us for doing that well Jeff
Bezos bought the Washington Post in 2013
and after uh Google and Facebook
snatched up most of these advertising
models hedge funds like Alden Global
Capital everything's been Consolidated
newspapers are gone investigative
journalism is gone ABC News cut their
whole investigative Bureau and Jeff
Bezos in an extraordinary admission
of the power of narrative Amplified
through big Tech through his ownership
The Washington Post said quote on a
medium post my ownership of the post is
something I will be most proud of when
I'm 90 and reviewing my life not his
rocket Dr Evil rocket ship company not
his Washington not not his Amazon
company no no his ownership The
Washington Post is his biggest
achievement and I found that really a
amazing insight into the power of
narrative I think the Washington Post in
the New York Times I may be giving them
too much credit are more powerful than
all three branches of government because
government speaks through them big Tech
prefers them in their algorithms big
Tech doesn't do any journalism they just
prefer what do you think wait did Bezos
say that before he became a Spaceman yes
with his wiener rocket he's not proud of
his weiner rocket yeah I mean although
he was formulating that but just one
extra point here it's not just hedge
funds it's not just just Jeff Bezos it's
also Bill Gates that donates hundreds of
millions of dollars to the corporate
media they don't they don't need
donations but they willingly take it and
with that money of course Comes The
Narrative that they push
if you're if you're one of the
higher-ups these companies and I've seen
this firsthand and you're looking at
your bottom line you don't care about
the politics of the individual person
writing stories you just don't want to
lose money the guys who run the
businesses don't care about news I I've
when I was at that ABC News company that
ABC Fusion their attitude from the at
the higher level was what are we going
to get clicks on so hire the people who
write about the things you think will
get clicks the marketing guys then said
we got to do woke stuff that's the way
forward okay then hire young woke people
and tell them to write about what they
care about they didn't they didn't care
if it was real they didn't care I was
told
what I side with the audience they said
side with the audience that means if
there is a new story that is factual
that will be offensive to the audience
we don't cover it that's that's the
modern uh like I mentioned with the New
York Times or I should say to to quote I
think it was Bhatia uh Angar Sargon that
the New York Times has found Their
audience they've said screw everybody
else and that's what they're going for
but that's what almost every
organization does especially right now I
don't care I don't care who they are 90
of all media Outlets are like we've got
an audience and we're going to cater to
that audience and that's the wrong
that's the inverse of what they ought to
be doing right there's a journalist
named Clarence Jones and he wrote We he
wrote about journalism that journalistic
Publishers need to be like bosses with
balls they need to have integrity
Veritas we're a non-profit people say
what's your business model we have you
know 800 000 people give us money
sometimes a dollar sometimes ten
thousand dollars but we choose the
hardest stories and we don't settle
lawsuits because
and this is the real Crux of This Book
American muckraker secrecy transparency
we don't set a lawsuits Tim because I
don't fear people inspecting my
operation please do depose me I like
being deposed they don't like being
deposed because when they enter
Discovery process of litigation you can
see all the lies under oath did you guys
know that uh Donald Trump at Israel in
Arizona banned fjb icons and merchandise
and shirts and all that stuff and yep I
got no problem we have that on
timcast.com we have a full report where
the security guys telling people to take
their shirts off take their hats off you
know so people will say that you know
this show or me or Trump supporters are
right wing I think the splc was like Tim
Poole is a right wing you know something
or other who supports Trump and I'm like
uh no I just don't lie about him like
Luke amazingly respectful of what Trump
did I really respect that banning fjp
that he banned it I mean and a lot of a
lot of trump supporters did well he said
this he said I don't like that but he
had four years of people saying that to
him as the president and I think he
probably really knows how much that
sucks to be like in charge of everything
and have people keep saying like you
know FDT at you all the time yeah but
you said this he said this on the heels
right after saying that it's hard to
criticize Joe Biden because Joe Biden
complimented him on all the work that he
did with the vaccine well that right but
but that's sort of a that's a different
situation I mean and also let's not
forget like Donald Trump was a president
he was holding executive office uh
has there ever been a president who's
really worthwhile I mean come on like
this is I think they should be
criticized
I agree too that's the point I don't
want it but I respect a former president
saying don't say that about the current
president but the I respect that the the
important issue I guess I'm trying to
get to is what the media is willing to
say who they're willing to criticize how
often does CNN run you know Joe Biden
has screwed this up screwed that up
screwed this up they did they I was it
Trump's coverage was 98 negative and
don't get me wrong there is a lot of
negative coverage coverage about Joe
Biden and I think what happens is around
August of last year when we saw this
flip in approval rating like you were
mentioning once someone says something
it makes it okay for the establishment
or for the for the for the you know
whatever you want to call it Democratic
position for the most part all of a
sudden people start ragging on Biden and
then we see some articles popping up
where they're like okay maybe there's
something here but for the most part the
media is unwilling to step out of line
with their own audience and most and
some of that's economics and some of
that is because they there's been a
proximity to their sources they don't
want to bite the hand that feeds them
and that's the difference between sort
of the the journalism that we're talking
about in American muckraker and their
their journalism is to represent be the
Ombudsman for the the so-called
administrative State our whistleblowers
release information the administration
administrative state does not want
revealed let me tell the difference in
the world when a two-star general talks
to the New York Times via anonymously we
don't know the Cadence or intonation of
what that we don't know what what that
person is actually trying to say and now
they throw out these terms
misinformation and disinformation we've
talked about the New York Times lawsuit
that I'm in Brooklyn which is
fascinating because the New York Times
admitted Tim and the response to our
defamation lawsuit they got the facts
wrong and they still haven't corrected
the article they admitted in court they
got it wrong the guy had more than three
ballots they said it wasn't illegal they
admitted in court it was and the article
remains online uncorrected
been any fact Checkers on this one has
the New York Times Facebook traffic been
suppressed as a result the New York
Times thinks they're Above the Law no
I'm sure they think they're I say they
you know Dean bakay famously executive
out of New York Times Dean beckay says
we don't get religion the New York Times
thinks they're God yes they do they
thought they were God for a very long
time what force or or organization on
planet Earth can hold the New York Times
accountable can anyone they lie no one
cares Google and Twitter prefer them in
the algorithms I sue them I sued them we
sued them for defamation and one a
victory and they still haven't corrected
the article in fact they're attacking
the judge personally and viciously yeah
which is something you shouldn't do by
the way I I was surprised to see that to
be honest because you're just gonna make
the judge rule against you but the New
York Times is probably thinking in the
short term yeah we'll probably piss the
judge judge off in the long term he
won't he won't retain power and if it
goes to the court of appeals highest
court in New York state they don't care
and if it goes to the Supreme Court and
they lose they'll say Trump Court think
of there's nothing that can hold them
accountable and I think that I think
that they are more afraid than I am of
them I I know that to be true but this
term misinformation Tim I think it's
really about distrusting people to draw
the acceptable conclusion based upon
facts that are admittedly true I don't
think it's about untrue facts anymore I
think look let me let me pull up this
story and get your thoughts on it this
is uh ABC7 nearly half of Democrats say
fines and prison time appropriate for
questioning vaccines just questioning
them they also said there's I believe 45
percent would in turn uh the
unvaccinated meaning they would take you
to a designated isolated facility I
think 59 were in favor of house arrest
so when you see the alignment of the New
York Times when you see the media when
you see it there are this many people in
this country who are willing to outright
just arrest someone for speaking out
against them
it kind of sounds like it's beyond just
the media there's there's something
deeply rotten expanding or growing
within the core of the American Site
it's a core value it's it's it's a the
primary value of of American society
which are part of the American founding
I mean this goes back to you know
Cicero you have to have information to
make informed decisions and that's the
whole that's why the first amendment's
first is a cliche I question whether
half of Democrats actually believe that
I think that's probably I I'm skeptical
about the amount of people the media is
telling you actually what was the actual
question on the on the poll
I suppose that would be a good one we
could definitely look that up but I
think the scarier aspect here is that a
lot of these things that some of these
Democrats are calling for are policies
that are implemented already in other
parts of the world and Democrats and
other establishment statists want to
implement here in the United States 29
according to this Rasmussen poll of
Democrats supported taking children away
from people if they refuse to take the
vaccine that's a policy that has already
been instituted in some places in Canada
when we're talking about when we're
talking about detaining people that's
happening in Austria and Australia and
in other parts around the world already
so we have to understand that this
slippery slope to dystopian total
totalitarian nightmare crap whole
society is very close to happen because
of this kind of echo chamber delusional
thinking that's being perversed by the
corporate media so what I see happening
is that there are very evil people like
James mentioned earlier it's a battle
between good and evil who know full well
what they're doing and what their plans
are they want to lock you up they want
to take away your rights and they're
lying about you on perfect on purpose
gleefully willfully and we're having a
fairness battle I don't think that
they're going to win I'm actually quite
hopeful everyone's cynical and it pisses
me off I mean I talk about this too in
this book a chapter called propaganda
um consent must be informed not
manufactured all serious theories of
democracy were Republic which is also a
democracy including the economic theory
hinge on the notion that voters have
reliable access to information I think
technology allows us to do that again
let me remind your audience
I am banned on Twitter I my
organizations banned on Twitter and our
story was the number one trending story
in the world why because of the
information that we released
documents inside the Department of
Defense DARPA a Marine Corps Major
fellow at the Department of Defense
wrote about this covet and wrote about
the fact that uh it was too risky for
the Department of Defense to approve
um what was going on and that story it
was about the strength of the
information and I believe that human
nature is such that if people are able
to see it for themselves first hand
participant journalism not secondhand
Anonymous sources I think we're going to
prevent society's Collapse by continuing
to do that journalism I agree I think
it's working we I mentioned this with
you know CNN and MSNBC having a ratings
collapse getting back uh to the to the
the darkness of this when we see this
Paul from Rasmussen I do think it's fair
to point out that maybe maybe it's a bad
poll from his music maybe the questions
aren't right but who knows but I will
say this Kamala Harris raised was
raising money through Twitter to bail
out rioters you know in 2020 some of the
most extreme rights I've ever seen when
I talk to people
no no but but not only that but I mean
the riots were across the country so
when we when we're seeing some of the
worst riots we've seen in 50 years maybe
and I talk to people about the potential
for civil conflicts civil unrest or
whatever and they say oh it's not that
bad it's because we're frogs in a pot
that are boiling when Andy you report on
this stuff you you expose who these
violent extremists are
the media lies about you all of these
different institutions lie about you
they make things up it there there is
there is I don't know how you describe
it I call it a cult there they are in
they're in line with each other but it's
not like they actively collude at a
national level where like a message goes
out and say everyone say Andy knows you
know wrong they just all do it
yeah I I was quite naive in in 2019
before I became more of a well-known
figure and I was just Regional person in
the Pacific Northwest after my uh
assault uh in the summer of 2019 that
punches kicks in the the milkshakes the
hospitalization for the traumatic brain
injury
um I wasn't naive enough at the time
that I thought the media organizations
would be out to support me I remember
Jake topper I believe was one of the
very few Center left journalists who
issued a tweet that condemned what
happened to me and I really appreciated
that and he got so much blah blah
blowback that he ended up deleting that
and then all the hit pieces came out in
a way that seemed sort of coordinated
and James to speak to us and I was
watching kind of in real time with in
Fascination at how they can destroy
someone's reputation so uh there was
initial outpouring support for me so
then what happened was a local blog in
Portland interviewed somebody and gave
this person a pseudonym so I have no
idea who this person is who accused me
of uh being in collaboration with this
far-right group in Portland so one I
couldn't I couldn't confront my accuser
uh legally I couldn't do anything either
we don't even know the identity of this
person so we can't even write a cease
and desist about her and then this
damning story and headline which is
false from the port that was published
in the Portland Mercury they never
reached out to me for comment by the way
was then repeated in other Publications
like uh slay and and box etc etc and
then that is cited in your in your
Wikipedia and then when somebody Googles
you who doesn't know who you are that's
the first thing they see and that is
your reputation I I wonder how long it's
going to last though you know they go
after Joe Rogan the most popular podcast
in the world and the stupidest thing you
can do is lie about Joe because the 11
million people on average who watches
show the 50 million who've seen some of
his biggest shows the people who are
fans of MMA and know him or who would
just watch his Netflix stand up there
they see this story and they go yeah
that's not true and all of a sudden you
lie about someone as popular as Joe and
people start waking up and now we're
starting to see it we're seeing a major
shift this uh poll came out Gallop
release that's one of the most credible
polling institutions that as of the
fourth quarter from 21 more people
identify is Republican or republican
leaning than Democrat for the first time
since I believe it was 1991. there
actually may have been a period around
the 2000s where it was fairly even
between the two but this is a gap now
five points right I'm not saying
Republicans are the right answer or that
you know Democrats are always the wrong
answer but regular people are looking at
the establishment they're associating it
with one side of the political spectrum
and saying I don't have anything to do
with it well it's not just Joe it's Joe
also influencing people like Dana White
influencing people like Aaron Rodgers
that are going out there and speaking
these larger truths and some people
would say breaking the mass psychosis
the mass formation psychosis that of
course the corporate media in unison
tells us doesn't exist as of course the
financial times literally calls for
psyops as of course even the Canadian
joint Operations Command even admittedly
said that they have relied on proper
propaganda techniques used in
Afghanistan with covid because they saw
it as a unique opportunity to test out
their propaganda
you know what you were saying about uh
Joe Rogan that's why they try and
silence him that's why these doctors and
researchers and scientists came out to
try and not fair to call him that what
not fair to call on the doctors anymore
a campus it was less than 100 medical
doctors some of them not even practice
did they have like a dentist okay so the
the letter written by a bunch of hacks
who a few of whom claimed to be doctors
apparently
um you know they're going after Joe
Rogan they're going after all of these
people because they don't uh they don't
understand that the American people can
see lies that they can see you know
these falsehoods that are being
forced upon them and you know Americans
go after the truth that's one of I think
but I think I want to go back to it
characteristics was saying because
you're you're talking to a man here who
is effectively suffered I think that's
fair to say it's some form or another
this is traumatic I'll speak personally
I I suffered a kind of a form of PTSD
after my New Orleans incarceration
and I was reminded of that
after the FBI rate at least for a day or
two I did do people say are you scared
well of course you're human
I mean I I've pretty much removed most
of my desire to be liked by these people
I'm almost down to completely zero I'm
never going to be fully zero because I'd
be a sociopath if I was Zero but I just
want to talk a little about that for a
minute because it's a theme that I think
is very important to discuss here
because it is a prerequisite for being
effective
you know I wrote about this that that
this is an age where the loss of one's
Twitter account is treated like the loss
of one's life imagine if everyone
watching this did not care if they took
away the Twitter account what impact
could they have on you your reputation
what does that mean your Wikipedia page
taking away de-platforming you
the moment you stop worrying about that
and you don't let that handcuff you pun
intended is the moment you're actually
able to actually be free to do the
things and do the journalism and I and I
know what it's like I articulate this in
words better than I I can off the cuff
no one can deprive me of my reputation
or Andy of your reputation
they've already been deprived we've
already been deprived of that by by
declarations from credible journalists
that's an incredible journalists how are
these journalists credible they're
credible by virtue of the decree that
they are indeed credible because they
say so and to see that happen it's
traumatizing it can make an otherwise
confident man question your own
perception of reality and in the
beginning it did in the beginning of my
journey I question my own perception of
reality
and but once you get through that and
get through the other side of it which I
think you have I think any any Survivor
of that sort of abuse develops
superpowers like you're you're a
stronger man than you were you're a
better journalist than you were and
you're wiser than you were and what I've
learned is the moment you know I've said
this to you before this is cliche the
moment you really stop caring about what
Wikipedia thinks of you and what Jack
Dorsey thinks of you they totally taken
away our Twitter accounts Eric lost his
this week we have no more Twitter
accounts we're still trending on Twitter
Jack's gone for all you know he actually
likes it for Jack is a metadim for
whoever the CEO is but the moment you
stop giving a [ __ ] about what they think
about you is the moment you're free oh
yeah it was it was a magic moment I
remember uh during Occupy Wall Street I
got a big surge of followers on Twitter
and with that a big surge of people
saying really mean things to me and it
was the first time I'd ever experienced
a wave of hundreds and thousands
hundreds to thousands of people just
saying the nastiest fake things about me
and for a minute I kind of freaked out I
was like what does this mean for me what
is this going to be what is it what is
it going to do am I going to be able to
keep doing this am I going to be able to
work and then went to bed and woke up
made some food had some bacon watched
some TV and then I was like nothing's
happening it gives you tough skin but
nothing happened and then and then
nothing helps a lot of things it's true
but I'm just like I'm living my life
like normal and after a little while I
was like I just figured something out I
can turn off the notifications and then
it doesn't exist anymore yeah and there
we are now I just don't have
notifications turned on why listen to
these people and being offended is a
choice people need to understand that if
someone is attacking you if you're
giving them power in that by reacting to
it you're you're playing into their
games and I think a lot of us in this
room have dealt with a lot of crazy
stuff me and Tim had to deal with the
police raid as well uh you know guns in
the face everything you know I was
arrested I was beat up Andy you were
beat up and Tim you were jumped I think
you know James you went through your
stuff and then the the amount of
craziness that we have to deal with we
have to understand is nothing new this
is something that of course the the the
people who don't like the bigger truths
exposed usually those are the techniques
they use against Effective People
exposing them look what happened to MLK
look how the FBI treated him the FBI
literally spied on him they got tapes of
him they sent him letters trying to get
him to commit suicide and this is the
Federal Bureau of Investigations decades
ago going after people who are changing
society and I would argue that the world
is round and that catches up with the
bad guys yes they did all those things
to him and it is Martin Luther King day
but as Martin Luther King said the Ark
of the moral Universe bends long but it
bends towards justice so the bad guys
don't get I've seen in my life these bad
guys it always catches up to them you
have to get away with it for a little
while but right you know look so we we
talked a bit about law enforcement we
FBI going after uh you James but I'm
interested to hear from you Andy you're
dealing with it with a different kind of
bad guy you're dealing with
extremist organizations that are really
angry you've been exposing a lot of
their people and their their violent
groundwork we can call it not only are
you dealing with these people making up
lies about you posting constantly but
physically attacking you and threatening
you so I'm interested in in this
perspective your take on journalism you
know we've heard from James on the
institutional Powers but what's
happening with groups like antifa and
these other far left extremists
targeting you
I well one crucially what makes them
particularly empowered is uh their
the narratives that they are able to
spread in the mainstream press uh
haven't really been challenged
you see it every day so
um
the various riots that happened after
Trump were elected were treated
essentially peaceful protests of people
reacting in Anger against his election
win rather than rather than as people
who were rejecting and using violence to
voice their opposition to a uh the
electoral process you're saying that
there was an Insurrection among the far
left in DC where they smashed windows
and set limousines on fire and were
attacking people
yeah so the language really matters
right yeah language really matters what
what pay attention to what is described
as a peaceful protest mostly piece of
protests versus uh Insurrection right
like they the it's not the differences
are uh uh that contrast is intentional
and
um antifa rely on allies in the Press
because obviously what they do is would
be unpalatable for the majority of the
public if the public was accurately
informed this you know there's wanton
acts of Austin maiming and injuries of
other people killing people carrying out
terrorist attacks such as attacks on
government buildings government
facilities police stations uh trying to
derail uh trains they actually did
derail train didn't they yeah there were
two convictions last year in Washington
state and that claim where's the Ma I'm
sorry I started but where is CNN
Headline breaking New York Times front
page far left extremist derail train I
mean that didn't happen they didn't they
didn't talk about it it was an attempt
to derailing attempted derail derailing
but which you know the charges was under
uh the anti-terrorism statutes in the
federal law so there were two young
women the claim of responsibility was
posted on this far left extremist group
site called it's going down which was
ban and by Facebook by the way last year
still operates openly on Twitter
a trump supporter could fart in DC and
it becomes a headline story
extremists attempt to derail a train
what were they doing their point
concrete or something like that I don't
get into too much detail but they were
trying to sabotage train tracks which
can cause not only excessive you know
property damage but could kill people
that's that's the craziest thing about
it that that is an attempt to kill and
the the amount of damage from derailing
these trains as much as many people on
the left don't like to get into the
economics of it it could cause people
great suffering in terms of not being
able to eat there poor people who rely
on food coming in and resources from
from local governments to help them this
level of disruption could have literally
killed people directly involved in the
train and then have massive
repercussions for the poor and the
suffering in these cities no news
coverage where is it where's the where's
the big story where's the national
conversation where's where's CNN to go
out and be like this is is insane these
conversations it doesn't happen yeah
well the point you're making is
sometimes by not reporting you are
reinforcing a particular narrative and
that's what happens and there are so few
people uh who are focused on the
anti-fobeat that it makes uh the number
the few of us who do it really subjected
to actual violence continued thoughts of
violence and threats of violence against
our family and if you happen to live uh
in a city like I lived in Portland
Oregon where in my view the the rule of
laws compromise police departments don't
have the resources to respond and the
local government is so corrupt that they
express support for these extremists
then you haven't essentially a sort of a
approval problem why do you think
doctors why do you think that other
people that other outlets and other
journalists don't want to cover these
guys
uh because a few journalists who have
who are from establishment press uh uh
experience what it's like to be suddenly
targeted online so you think it's a fear
thing yes they don't want to do it
because they're afraid yeah it's also
the ideological thing I think for lack
of better word communism Communists
don't want to breach discipline for it
to do so would be an active blasphemy
like when Jake Dapper takes his tweet
down right that's crazy that is crazy to
do that where's the principle I tweet
stupid things all the time and get
mocked for I just leave them up I don't
care right like I I'll delete something
if I tweet it right away there's a typo
or like a word is it's not phrased
properly but I get people being like Oh
your tweets so now I'm like I don't know
whatever I said it you know they they
have this is the challenge of our Brave
New World that they will inflict almost
any type of Injustice for their cause it
defies reason it defies logic they'll
and and and I have I have respect I mean
this in kind of a dark way I have so
much respect for them I see it the
Christian I just get interviewed as a
Christian magazine earlier today and
they wanted advice I'm like grow a pair
of balls you guys love going to church
but beyond praying what the hell are you
doing
the Communists have faith and it's a
faith that they live or die by they want
to give up their lives well that's their
cause are they really who
I mean they're willing to burn down
buildings they're willing to burn down
Billings buildings but they're not
willing to give up their lives some of
them no we've seen look we've seen them
giving up their lives maybe it wouldn't
be incarcerated I mean history but I
mean I'm talking about recently so I
mean if we look at for example
um protests at the capitol for example I
was talking to an attorney Marina madvin
who represents you guys probably know
who she is represents some January 6th
protesters or writers whatever you want
to say and um there's this Rabbi who
she's representing who is being charged
with parading and it's a misdemeanor and
her argument
um he's you know they're trying to
sentence him to all this long prison
term well longer than necessary like six
I don't know some days prison term
um and her argument is that people who
were arrested for protesting in the
capital against Brett Kavanaugh got a 50
fine yeah so why is this Rabbi getting
like an excessive sentence and excessive
of fine when he was in there for less
time for like five minutes and left
because it's a cult it's obvious that
the machine is slanted in One Direction
Right we've all said in a variety of
ways the institutions are protecting one
side and demonizing the other right but
in terms of protesters right right what
got charged with fifty dollars she knows
she's not gonna have to get that that's
that's not that's not that she knows
she's only enough for the leftists know
that they have legal resources behind
them the right doesn't have that right
they have the national lawyers Guild
behind them so they don't they're giving
them that's not true they're given
trainings on what to do they're willing
to do this they're willing to sacrifice
each other they're willing to a certain
degree to sacrifice themselves now many
of them may not think they're going to
lose their lives completely but they
enter these positions I've been to these
meetings Luke and I were at a big a big
meeting in France and they said everyone
outright you could end up in prison for
the rest of your lives in charge of
terrorism and they say they say okay so
when I see a dude working at Taco Bell
and he's got a black lives matter mask
and his manager says take the mask off
because the black lives matter thing get
a new one or you're fired and he says
then fire me the far left screams they
make demands and Taco Bell backs down
and says we're sorry the right does
nothing they do nothing it's the
Revolutionary heart of Communism I think
it's the power to to act upon their
convictions and I think history is
replete with accounts of this Whitaker
Chambers wrote about it Douglas Hyde
wrote about it he converted from
communism to Catholicism there's there's
a lot of examples of people it's it's at
the heart of their for lack of better
word religion
and I think they're willing to act upon
their ideals and from my perspective I
think we can learn from their faith to
act not break the law but not worry
about being shamed in some regards the
modern day equivalent of giving up your
your Lively life livelihood you're
giving up your livelihood and your
reputation yeah and your and your
accounts they don't care we had Darren
for speaking out we had darrenheit
they're not afraid they're not afraid
Darren Beatty said he thinks that
they're right and I'm probably I'm
paraphrased but I think the general idea
was the right is actually more prone to
cancel culture than the left because the
right has more people scared of the
mainstream opinion against them so
they're willing to tell people who are
either to the right of Center or you
know or more conservative traditional
conservative they're not going to defend
them and you see this in Congress even
Marjorie Taylor green gets condemned and
booted off her her committee assignments
because the Republican Party panics
meanwhile ilhan Omar can say whatever
she wants
and then Donald Trump just wants to be
liked by the New York Times it needs to
be liked by the corporate institutions
and that kind of train of thinking you
know it's not going to there are
Republicans who care more about the
opinion of the New York Times and the
opinion of their own Constitution that
is exactly the point and until they stop
caring they can't be effective and it
and it comes down to the faith that I've
been saying this for years and I don't
know how else to say it sounds like a
cliche but the moment the Republican
party stops being humili you give them
that power
we give them that power that's not a
power they have it's only a power if you
give it to them
and the moment you stop caring and you
stop giving them then you're free to
actually do but but they won't because a
lot of the people in the Republican
Party aren't there for the right reason
you want to know why they don't like you
James because you change the news cycle
how is the news cycle set the New York
Times CNN these big companies decide
there's a big story and then people in
politics try and jump on it to address
the issue and I wonder that sometimes
I'm like how is it that the New York
Times just decides to run a headline
story and all of a sudden that's what
we're talking about but something
interesting happens with Veritas you
report a story and it Trends number one
on Twitter all of a sudden they're
forced to address it and they don't like
doing that I want to get even deeper on
you this is a Daily Beast headline by
Lloyd Grove and they tried to do this
shame crap with me they tried to get me
I'm so sorry I apologize I shouldn't
have done and the headline reads
it's impossible to shame James O'Keefe
that's a badge of honor right there do
you understand we should frame this and
put it in our bathroom at headquarters
do you understand now how the game is
played the whole point
the whole point
shame you when they couldn't when
they're modus operand and here's what's
scary when they couldn't shame you the
FBI shows up when they couldn't shame
Andy they found him in the street they
beat him up well the running out of
arrows aren't they because how do you
exceed you know how aggressive it is for
a for the FBI to execute a search
warrant against an American journalist
the Attorney General of the United
States expressly forbids it in a memo by
Merrick Garland in July you do not
execute search warrants against
journalists particularly for this issue
they probably broke the law and that
doesn't that show kind of a bit of
desperation yeah absolutely I I wonder
if there's something else we don't know
yet the FBI maybe got worried that you
had a whistleblower with some
information and the only way they could
figure out what stories you were working
on was to drum up some fake search
warrant to get access to your doctor
well the problem with that strategy is
that most of my employees I'm the CEO of
the company I I do some reporting but
not all most of our employees are the
ones with sources and they didn't take
their phones
well they don't know what to do I think
I think they're panicked they're
desperate we can see it with like like
you mentioned Libby how they're going
after these January 6 guys with extreme
uh charges relative to what the left has
done and we had an Insurrection in 2017.
Luke and I were there on the ground we
saw conspiracy charges against all of
these you know black-clad individuals
who are smashing Windows setting fires
and most of them just got let go they
couldn't hold any charges against them
well and that goes on in so many of
these cities that are Democrat run and
they've just taken that strategy and
they're using it all over the place
gascon and the D.A in La does this catch
and release thing that's not working the
the new D.A in New York has promised to
do something very similar uh it's going
to make the city that is crumbling even
worse in New York just really quickly in
New York there was activists being
arrested for eating without a vax pass
eating without permission from the
government when a woman was murdered
yards away from them so the police is
prioritizing vaccine domestic passports
over literal murders that happen this is
happening under the Eric Adams
Administration that promised campaigned
to be tough on crime and this is
happening in the city right now it's
absolutely ridiculous well they also
promise to be uh tough on vaccine
mandates and they've continued that as
well
to the extent where people are literally
being thrown in front of trains wow and
they're not doing anything and they're
arresting people who don't have people
have been permission from the government
in front of trends for some time uh
that's actually not new in the city
although it is horrifying the crime is
up there's crime is up yeah yeah no it's
a disaster it's a disaster for sure
Andy and I were talking about this
earlier that um so many of these cities
that are Democrat run
what was our conversation
but we were talking about that by mid to
mid December there were a dozen cities
in America that had surpassed its
historical record on homicides and
murders Portland being one of them uh
and there were 11 others this is just
mid-December I'm not sure if they were
by then you know the end of 2021 if
there were more than that
um it's a direct consequence uh that
will be felt for years and years of the
um
the the political and social changes in
our culture after George Floyd died that
was right and it's like social justice
uh social justice initiatives are not
going to make cities safer it turns out
it's just going to make it worse for the
very people that you're claiming to try
and protect but I wonder if that's you
know
these people aren't trying to protect
anybody well they're trying to protect
themselves and the people who read the
New York Times I think it's worth trying
to protect criminals I I think it's
worse than that it's it's the chaos that
destroys A system that allows them to
exploit it they're letting people out of
prisons because it creates crime they're
doing these they're setting forth these
policies that are making everyone's
lives genuinely worse and more chaotic
than as everything gets crazy they come
out and say we're the solution give us
the power they they they enact policies
that destroy the system and then tell
you they're the only solution yes they
do do that
uh and then they enact further policies
that continue to destroy things yes I
think they do do that is another good
way to say it too because these policies
are are crap yeah they don't make sense
they they come out and often by decree
yeah they're pushing these policies well
and of course we've had we've had
nothing but rule by decree for the past
two years right these executive orders
have got to stop the the emergency
powers that have been given to Governors
and Mayors have got to end the people
need their representation in New York
City we're being mandated without
representation at this point you know
it's like some Stamp Act [ __ ] is
that we've got going on they're
mandating you guys get three vaccines
now or is it still two it's still the
two but you know but cases are through
the roof anyway and there's room on
those Vex cards for a whole bunch of
more crap that they can interact with us
with that's what the conspiracy
theorists were saying like why is there
foreign
500 million times he's tested negative
500 million times he was around me when
I got coveted he was around his dad when
his dad got coveted he keeps being fine
like if he's fine what do we what do we
need this for so many kids are fine
they're mad they're requiring
five-year-olds not only be vaccinated
but also wear a face mask just to go to
you know like whatever the Olive Garden
in Times Square which I don't know why
anyone wants to go there but still
anywhere to go to the met I have a
question have any of the politicians or
activists who demand ended that police
be defunded apologize that their
project resulted in historical numbers
of black and brown people invulnerable
people dying in urban areas they just
ignore that that fact
they ignore it there I mean we saw that
video where the two antifa women are
vandalizing the property and two young
black women say why are you doing this
get out of here we don't want this look
we're doing it to help you we're helping
you it's like no you're not you're
destroying our community yeah yeah I
I'll tell you that story when I was in
Ferguson when the young black man black
man linked arms to defend the the liquor
store where Michael Brown had bought the
uh the cigarette or had stolen the
cigarillos and they were interviewed by
Al Jazeera and they said these people
looting and raiding our stores don't
live here man
but you know what we end up seeing from
I think it was the new Republic I can't
remember which Outlet it was so forgive
me if it wasn't but uh in defense of
looting
as people who live in the community were
begging for the violence to stop and
outside forces were exploiting it and
burning down their buildings
prominent left-wing activist media said
it was a good thing yeah they were they
were it was it was Revolution and I'm
like the people who live there aren't
doing this I'm glad you brought that
brought that up NPR did a very glowing
interview with the author of that book
Vicki osterwell yes that's correct
and this is why narrative is important
because when the mainstream left
essentially puts out this
um is platforming people
who are arguing in support of violent
extremism in criminality
that shifts the whole Overton window and
I think we've seen that very clear we've
seen that slowly in the last six years
in the opinion section of the New York
Times I mean they publish some really
awful things like uh I'm still disturbed
by that one piece of the the parent
asking if his black child should have
white friends yeah that was really
upsetting that was the Charles blow
story I think wasn't it uh I don't
recall so um yeah that that shifts and
uh we've seen you know what as all that
violence was happening in 2020 where
where it wasn't just property
destruction we had 20 at least 26 people
who died as a result and there were
peripheral deaths too so there were
there were some instances where people
died indirectly as a result of the riots
like Rosemary roads being closed uh
ambulances being blocked things like
that and then you had the overt murders
people like David Dorne who were just
just killed in these riots reporting
that I will always give a shout out to
Michael Tracy where he actually drove to
these small towns yeah it was it was
ikau and Yanka sorry it was what for
what that was the author yeah author of
it I had it wrong oh okay can my
children be friends with whites Michael
Tracy went he drove across the country
and he went to these very small towns
and he saw boarded up Windows spray
paint saying please don't hurt us things
like that oh I saw myself uh in so I was
in the Capitol Hill autonomous Zone Chas
in in Seattle this is where
BLM far left extremist and antifa took
over six blocks of a major American city
created a hard border and had people
with guns guarding these uh checkpoints
and it was allowed to go on three weeks
people died there on the win and this
was a really heavily densely populated
area the businesses on there had signs
that said black owned business Asian
owned business person of color owned
business uh sort of these I mean it
seems really kind of like medieval right
it's like please please don't harm us
because every inch of that entire six
boxes vandalized
um
I have to wonder you know uh we often
talk about Civil War or civil unrest or
whatever fun uh in a in I guess a funny
uh twist or whatever or however you want
to describe it when Luke was reading
about post-pandemic civil unrest is when
we got swatted so I'm I'm curious Luke
if we never actually I don't think I
have to flesh out what was going on with
that as we're looking at what happened
with Chaz and with Minnesota and with
all this stuff I think there's a real
possibility that Not only was it were we
already likely to see civil unrest
because of the pandemic lockdowns but
you add to this the fact that black
lives matter rhetoric and writing over
the past few years has never been
checked it has never been held to
account
I I think that's going to lead to
something you know substantial
especially when you consider the
economic factors that are also adding a
lot of stress to the entire system with
people finding it harder and harder just
to find a commonly household used items
the the store shelves are also being
emptied not just because of the winter
storm but because of the global supply
chain shortages and the problems that
have started that we still haven't felt
the full effects of so when you combine
all of that and the historical pretext
for unrest when it comes to pandemics
this is a recipe for disaster especially
at the state that the United States is
in right now with what people are
calling a decline of an Empire there's a
lot of things coming together all at
once but it's it's a storm that's
absolutely uh dangerous to be in the BLM
riots and the antifreeze it wasn't that
they were only unchecked they were
encouraged and they were encouraged
those Riders were encouraged to flout
covert restrictions so I remember in
June 2020 just a real quick interjection
actually it was
um one article said that they actually
reduced the spread of covet yes no joke
no joke they reported that well Andrew
Cuomo said and de Blasio said that if uh
contract Tracer spoke to people who had
been protesting for social justice they
were not to ask them if they had been
you know not to ask people have you been
doing this in order to help the contract
tracing but it was in June of 2020 that
there was a 10 000 person protest
outside of the Brooklyn Museum of Art in
uh well in Brooklyn ten thousand people
out protesting to end violence against
black Trans people
and this was the mayor said this was
more important than coveted restrictions
and it was it was literally at that
moment like I was already sort of done
with this pandemic in May I can't you
know whatever and then at that moment I
was like and everything you have said
and everything you are now going to say
is a complete and total fabrication it's
fully a lie as soon as there's 10 000
people allowed to hang out outside the
Brooklyn Museum and protest uh you know
supporting black Trans lives and me and
my kid can't go to the movies and we
can't go to the met and we can't do
anything everything you are you are
thoroughly discredited 100 discredited
the government entirely I I think you
know in New York state and in the city I
think I remember watching de Blasio on
the corporate media I think it was CNN
scheister yeah announcing hey we're
going to restrict this you can't go to
the movies you can't go to the
supermarket you can't eat at restaurants
you can't do this this and this and then
he was asked what about the protest he's
like oh they're Justified how
and it was probably a bunch of these
same stupid doctors and researchers and
scientists who wrote the Rogan letter
who penned that letter saying that
racial Justice protests are a reasonable
reason to not adhere to covert
restrictions you mean the dentists and
nursing students
and the Cannabis farmer I got respected
the guy who's farming cannabis but I
don't think he should be yeah he's a
non-board certified veterinarians yeah
back alley veterinarians I don't like
what Joe Rogan's talking about the
veterinary abortionist oh man sorry
but but I I wanna I Wanna Live it back
to you know what James saying James
saying we're optimistic or he's
optimistic I'm optimistic yeah I take a
look at the declining ratings of these
institutions I take a look at we have
the story actually from the
post-millennial Red Wave poll shows
dramatic shift in party preference from
Democrat to Republican at the end of
2021. so this is from Gallup one of the
most credible appalling institutions so
they say and we can see that around the
third quarter there was a big decline in
the shift occurring and by quarter four
of 121 Republican sent identification
outweighed Democrat by Five Points this
for the first time in a couple like 20
years uh maybe there was a period I
think in like 2010s where it was fairly
even but we haven't seen this pronounced
of of uh of a flip since like 91. now I
don't think Republicans are necessarily
the answer I think voting in the
primaries and voting for people who care
about this country is the answer but the
fact that people are breaking away from
The Establishment narratives from
declining ratings to party shift I think
matters I think I think it's it's
grounds for optimism right well I keep
on plugging my book but the second book
you should reread every year is 1984
which is the year I was born
and in this book Winston sign the win
the protagonist Winston 1984 says the
party the party is a metaphor for what
we're talking about tells you to reject
the evidence of your own eyes and ears
Winston said it is the final most
essential commandment is the number one
rule don't trust your own eyes and years
but the moment propaganda becomes
apparent it loses its effect and I think
what's happening right now is people are
starting to wake up and there and you
look I think you're right I think
they're losing like a what do you call
it a dog that was an animal that was
caged or something I like that metaphor
a trapped animal and I think this is
also why in 1984 they made them repeat
two plus two equals five because it's
nonsensical and they couldn't have
common sense they couldn't have rational
debate and discussion they needed to of
course obey this the state and the
controllers at all it's the it's the uh
Emmanuel Goldstein manual 1984 it
requires a moment-to-moment flexibility
in the treatment of facts so that scene
you're talking about where they're
torturing Winston you know two plus two
equals is five and Winston's like
spoiler alert for people sorry
in case you haven't read it since high
school and he's like I don't understand
two plus two equals four and it says and
finally Winston because he's being
tortured he says well two plus two is
whatever you want it to be exactly but I
feel like there are four lights I feel
like yes this is America damn it this is
America and I think we're different than
any other country in the history of the
world
um I just don't think we're I'm hopeful
because I think people are understand
what's happening what what the danger
Tim is that most people are afraid and
that Ma pension mortgage ma kids well
good luck to your kids because we don't
change this maybe your kids will be
holding bayonets or whatever the modern
equivalent of a bayonet will be so we
better give up our pensions and our
mortgages there's more to life than my
mortgage it's really you know it's it's
very difficult when you have so much to
lose what's the point of living what's
the point of living what's the point of
life
this is the question what's the meaning
of life absolutely this is the question
I don't think there's an answer to what
is the meaning of life no no my
questions you posed a rhetorical
question to me and my
rhetorical question to you right what's
the point of life if without meaning you
know the pursuit of happiness well
there's also the pursuit of meaning sure
and the excuse that we're giving is
we're following orders there's a hundred
and twenty thousand what I'm saying is
if you have people who have a family and
they have a home and they want to
protect those things right they're going
to go to Great Lengths to protect those
things they're not going to give them up
until they're forced to if you can if
you can get dinner on the table and you
can go to your job you're going to do
those things that's what people do what
if you're being asked to do
unconstitutional legal things well then
we see people start to start to give
those things
and that's you know but that's a
different point for everybody when there
is a you live in a house and you're
surrounded by a wooded area and there is
a fire on the horizon you have people
saying well I think if we just sit
around and do nothing the fire
eventually won't hit us and we'll get
lucky and it's like or you can take
action now get your fan family out
before the fire destroys your home what
we're seeing right now is that people
aren't going willing to go to Great
Lengths to protect their friends and
family or their or their or their
children to make sure there's food in
the table they're looking at short-term
gains and long-term losses so the reason
I use the forest fire uh analogy is that
this is like check off with the trees
it's off the distance okay the fire is
not here right now I know there's a fire
I know there's a fire I know it is
destroying people's homes I know my
neighbors have lost everything but I'll
be fine I'm sure of it right they think
if they keep their head down
consultants and describes in the Google
log archipelago to survive at any price
and to survive at any price is the
danger because if you continue down this
road I like your analogy of long term
you're going to live in a lot in a
society which is permanently corrupted
wherever where the LIE becomes a
permanent form of existence and you have
to sell out your own family to not to
not you know go to the gulags when
you're breaking rocks in the gulags
there's going to be a guy 10 years older
and is going to go hey James I ever tell
you how about how my kid my kid played
soccer and you're gonna be like oh yeah
the worst part about the gulags is the
inevitable hunger strike because I like
to eat I get I get hangry but there's a
serious point because I this is I want
to go back to this point which you and I
disagree with because this is the this
is the issue I'm not defending people
for for not wanting to fight I'm saying
people don't want to fight right we're
I'm not asking everyone so this is so
this is my my Martin Luther moment but
we are at a Breaking Point here yeah
this is my Martin Luther moment this is
the issue at hand what we're talking
about you're nailing stuff on the door
that's it okay right now here I stand I
can do no other what we're talking about
you and I in this moment that's
everything I have people who have
families who who you know who are making
money for Facebook Pinterest they gave
it all up for the Public's right to know
and they did so as a leap of faith and
the American people protected them the
HHS whistleblower Jody she raised half a
million dollars after she gave up her
job for filming stuff in the emergency
room uh and Zach at Google Eric Cochran
at Pinterest said I'll fall to ashes one
day I want my life to mean something
after I'm gone those are his words not
mine sure I mean I've you know like I
lost everything because I wrote the
truth right right this happened to me
too and we need more kind of thing
happens to Andy all the time and we need
more people yes we need to speak up for
that but we also need to understand and
not condemn the people I think who who
don't do it I think we need to
understand those people but we should
encourage them at the same time as we
understand them
because there's too many of us to be
destroyed they're acquiescence their
compliance is literally leading us down
I'm sorry I profoundly disagree with you
there is a literally as I speak
thousands of DMS every day what can I do
help me I want to help I wanna I wanna I
wanna make a Sacrament good good so we
need to we need to create a mass
movement of those people we need to give
them an opportunity to fight people want
to fight in this country they don't know
what to do they want to do something
um but I I think with a hundred and
twenty thousand people the doj Tim
there's got to be one or two right I
just need one or two maybe I already
have them but I mean I need one or two
more there's got to be okay we're
following orders I get it you have your
mortgage to pay but
you're talking to a man who's been put
in handcuffs twice by the FBI for a
crime I didn't commit right and I would
like to believe that half the people in
my apartment actually were not bad bad
people at all I think they're very good
people I just think we're entering a
slippery slope
and we have to encourage people to do
the right thing and it will involve
without question it will involve
sacrifice and suffering it just will
nice unlike Dr Peterson well the police
officers and FBI agents that are
wrestling
well I'm sitting next to a man who got
thrown concrete milkshakes you know he
got physical physically assaulted for
what he went through my my only point
was to have empathy for the people who
are terrified of losing everything but
but those people
how does that affect the actual actions
that we're going to take
how does empathy affect the actions that
we're going today yes I don't think
condemning people gets them on yourself
have I done that I didn't say that you
did okay
I'm not condemning anybody I'm incred we
need to create a forum for people to
come forward we have to do this yes we
should all be encouraged we should be
encouraging each other to speak the
truth and to not be cowed by this
nonsense anymore I thoroughly agree with
you on that but the people arresting
James and the FBI agents that went after
him are making those excuses we need to
pay the mortgage we need to pay the
bills we need to make sure that my uh
you know kids are taken care of those
are the same kind of uh arguments that
I've heard made by corporate journalists
saying hey I just got to read this
script I just got to do what they tell
me to do because at the end of the day I
want to take care of myself that's not
what I'm defending but there's a lot of
people who use that kind of
justification even in the White House
you have to give up your pen that I
personally I was responding to you have
to give up I think point zero zero one
percent of people need to give up their
pension yes man could you imagine I
think you're probably right a thousand
people in one of these organizations
just came out and said we're willing to
sacrifice our pensions well then none of
them would if every single person at any
of these corrupt institutions if they
all just said we hereby all agree we
have Scruples and won't do these illegal
things yeah it wouldn't happen in the
first place I agree with that two
choices you can follow your conscience
or you can and and then you will lose
your livelihood or you could not follow
your conscience and
have a safe existence my view you know
on life growing up was never based on
tribalism and I think that's that's what
shapes my perspective today is that
there was no group identified with there
was nothing I saw that I said I need to
be a part of it was actually my whole
life was if I don't figure it out for
myself I'm in trouble yeah too many
people today are wrapped up in just
trying to fit in with whatever tribe
they think will keep them alive right we
see with uh with Ethan Klein he's the H3
podcast guy he deletes the Jordan
Peterson interviews that's such a that's
such a trash move but it's because in my
opinion if you look at his Instagram he
said YouTube uh gave me a strike I can't
work for a week because someone went to
an old video and flagged it and got it
removed here's a guy who's got a big
he's got a company of 10 people he's got
a a 10 million subscribers and because
of the rule changes he's getting banned
so what does he do he says I'm just
going to adhere to whatever they tell me
to do yeah any deletes the I'm going to
say that two plus two equals 5 because I
don't want the rat to eat my face yep
exactly that's what the or what was the
genius Room 101 but Room Room 101 nope
I don't know what your psychological
version of the Rat everyone's got their
fears but um this is a slippery slope
and I don't know I'm I'm just quoting
our whistleblowers that come to us all
of these people
it's not these are not my words they're
saying listen there's
I want my life to mean something and I
guess it is akin to what Jordan Peterson
talks about wasps wasps yeah if if the
establishment came to my house and
unloaded wasps into my house the show
would be off don't don't say that don't
he's he's just making a joke
don't give them ideas Tim don't tell
them the fear they're like Tim doesn't
actually scare cancellation put some
wasps in his building
you weren't afraid of the stink bugs I'm
actually not scared I don't think that
that could get you in 1984 the states
knew your biggest fear and for Winston
it was the fear of rats and that's why
they put a bucket with a rat in it and
it said the rat's going to eat your face
unless you obey the state so this is
again the dangers of the track trace and
database Society the society that has
the NSA snooping on every aspect of our
existence and it's not out of the realm
of possibility to compare our current
reality going towards the 1984 World it
was interesting brings up all the time
which is on on the money the vaccine
database thing so in April Jeff science
at the CDC said that there was going to
be no federal vaccine database Jen saki
said there was going to be no federal
vaccine credential and it actually turns
out that after the OSHA mandate went
through four federal workers this safety
guidelines agency said uh you know
helped to help federal agencies
implement the vaccine mandate they said
and you will have to keep a database of
who's been vaccinated and who isn't and
the reasons for why the people didn't
get vaccinated specifically religious
exemptions so it turns out that the OSHA
mandate supersedes everything else for
federal workers and there will be
a bunch of different Federal vaccine
databases at all for the employees at
all of these agencies and I and I think
unless I think it's very likely it will
happen yes I think so short of us
actually speaking out and people who
like watch the show share this show talk
about these ideas stand up for yourself
and I think more and more people are
doing that if they don't the Supreme
Court May strike down mandates for
private companies but give it five years
and it will be commonplace unless you
speak up now Charles Murray said that
government is in an advanced state of
sclerosis where Solutions are outside
the legislative process in the courts I
I think what we've experienced with the
New York Times lawsuit is is on point I
mean even if the Supreme Court were to
rule in my favor the New York Times
would say Trump judge Trump judge who
cares we don't care we're doing I mean
but does it matter to you
obviously winning against New York Times
is very important they defamed you they
cause you problems and money but for the
the snooty Elites in their Ivory Tower
with their wine you never convince them
right literally Gene Dean Becky had a
glass of chardonnay it's Pittsburgh with
this with his with his turtleneck and
Blazers so there's a story in this book
I I saw Dean Becky New York Times
Pittsburgh I was at one of literally at
the proverbial seat at the table I was
sitting next to Marty Baron and Dean
beckay through and I went to shake his
hand and he would think why would you
want to shake this horrible well maybe
there's a moment of humanity maybe maybe
he has a moment of levity no no he
whimpered and winced like a little
coward he wouldn't shake your hand he
wouldn't [ __ ] he turned around towards
the wall while holding I'm not making
this up a glass of wine wow and I and I
and at that moment I I I realized that
yeah there's you asked a question it's
not the satisfaction from the verdict
the satisfaction comes
in the discovery part of litigation
where you're exposing them
the only thing that
for lack of a better word Communists the
only thing that Communists fear
is being exposed
they do not fear the government in my
experience They Don't Fear the courts
They Don't Fear the only thing that will
hold them accountable is exposure and I
think litigation does that basically the
discovery process when you open up their
books when you record them in
depositions etc etc also when you guys
take a microphone and put it up to their
face and they start running away
that's also if you ever notice that they
don't want to engage Us in conversation
they want us to shut up I want them to
talk
interesting dichotomy right so so I I
see this with uh in the movie don't look
up have you seen it this is that Netflix
movie yeah yeah one of the scenes it's
basically in the movie The Republican
party is telling all of their you know
right-wing nut jobs not to look up at
the sky where the combat is coming to
destroy the planet so they don't and I'm
watching that and I'm like I think the
movie's funny it's poking fun at
everybody but the Republicans the
conservatives are the meme of debate me
it's it's Ben Shapiro chasing after AOC
being like why won't you debate me while
the left says leave me alone I don't
want to talk to you if anyone is telling
you not to look up it's CNN right not
the right the rights demanding you look
up and and the Biden Administration as
well that's saying that we need to stop
disinformation but they don't take any
questions from reporters and Dr fauci
Who today on the world economic Forum
Zoom call was literally saying we need
to fight disinformation from quote
Medical Health alongside of course uh
zizing ping who also was on the zoom
calls that goes well and they only I
didn't they identified disinformation
and misinformation as anything that goes
along goes against whatever the current
narrative is which is consistently
changing
it goes back to the moment-to-moment
flexibility in the treatment effects we
talk about engaging in conversation I
again I I tell my staff
um we welcome the inspectors that might
sound counter-intuitive you're an
undercover operation you have to keep
secrets we don't keep many Secrets Tim I
I tell it everything you do is going to
be watched
um The New York Times is required by
other ethical code to reach out for
comment they do do that via email but
they'll never print my response and when
I try to call them they hang up the
phone they hang up the phone they do
this clever thing where if your quote
hurts you it's in full if your quote
helps you they'll snip it or paraphrase
yeah one one such comment was please
respond all these things so I quoted the
judge in the defamation lawsuit you the
New York Times acted in disinformation
and deception I quoted a judge and the
New York Times published win Astro
comment Mr O'Keefe criticized the New
York Times well I didn't criticize the
New York Times I was quoting a Judicial
Authority so that's that's false a
statement effect isn't it it is and we
he sued them for defamation
so I mean so now we just put out our
quotes to the New York Times to our
audience we just film myself yeah
emailing the New York Times P I think
your audience wants Solutions I I think
we know they they chop the quotes they
take it out of context Solutions I had a
I had Robert Silverman which was his
hack reporter uh uh Daily Beast he
reached out to me I think around
midnight eastern time and said uh he was
trying to get comment he said I'll give
you until 12 30 a.m to respond this is
how entitled you know like they're doing
you the favor the writing a hit piece
yeah they contact you at the last hour
and then well most people are sleeping
at that time or not checking the email
and then uh yeah and then your comment
never makes it into the the published
Andy I was going to ask you how do you
deal with the media coverage that you
get dealt with do you have any kind of
legal battles or what's your strategy
when it comes to dealing with the media
that attacks you
um
well I've come to like James come to
ignore most of it uh unfortunately I
don't have the resources to do uh
lawsuits against everybody who defames
me and the uh in the US uh deaf proving
defamation in a court when your public
figure is extremely hard
and so uh the point of these negative
pieces is to sabotage and ruin someone's
reputation and also to to demoralize
them and to take up their time I think
it's been more effective for me to
ignore most of it when it's really
egregious and I'll respond uh I think
like so recently in December a few weeks
ago
um I got an email
um yeah a night from a journalist asking
me for a comment about this Federal
lawsuit that was filed against me for a
copyright violation that was first I've
heard of it so these two antifa
activists
extremists in Portland sued me for
retweeting their videos on Twitter okay
completely frivolous lawsuit but the
point wasn't necessarily about winning
it was about getting all of these
negative pieces out that said ending
those sued in federal court for stealing
journalist content that's really damning
for I mean if you're a journalist your
reputation really matters by the way
this there's only as as much as I say
you know I ignore this ignore that
reputation at the end of the day matters
when you're a journalist because your
reputation is your legitimacy that's how
people know that what you're reporting
out is accurate they can trust it
um and within less than two weeks the
the lawsuit was withdrawn and but so by
then you know who those left-wing uh
media sites are not going to write these
new uh follow-up stories about how this
was a frivolous lawsuit that was a waste
of everyone's time
um but you know on the record now people
Google me again in addition to all the
hit pieces before they see stuff like
this and now now it's forever that even
though the the lawsuit's gone they can
still say Andy no has been sued for
stealing content in the past and it'll
be forever but I I do have to issue a
very strong correction you see I stated
on this show that that lawsuit would be
dismissed in summary judgment and I was
wrong they withdrew it because it was a
frivolous lawsuit so it didn't even make
it that far but again it's the smear
that counts and that's what they were
going for at least in my opinion right
the object of persecution is to is
persecution is to break your will you
know that that's what they're trying to
do they're just trying to it's usually
these these litigation is an exercise
and just trying to shut you up break
your will bankrupt you Etc
all right let's go to super chats if uh
you haven't already get those super
chats in we're gonna take questions and
I'm gonna do my best to try and go
through good questions for you know for
everybody here so we can have some very
serious conversations and there's a ton
of super chats so I definitely won't be
able to read everybody's but smash that
like button go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have that members
only podcast up tonight we usually post
them around 11 or so p.m but uh let's
see what we got here just with we'll
start with some compliments Robert
dolvick says James Andy and Libby with
Tim is The journalistic Avengers
like he didn't put he didn't say Luke
that's fine that's fine that's okay
all right let's see what we get here I
want to try and find a a good question
for everybody
may I may I just ask the question Eric
sent me absolutely yo Mr O'Keefe we
gotta know boxes are briefs
and this is your guys
everyone loves to talk about me and my I
don't know what they're called I guess
boxer briefs
it's just visual it's just a very visual
image I mean it's gonna in the film
version that's gonna be like on the
poster you think there's going to be a
film made about it don't you think there
ought to be we do have a super great
film we did have a super chat saying Mr
O'Keefe boxes are brief who would who
would cast who would be the person that
would play me I don't know who do you
want
anyways I'm sorry I took the podium away
from you too oh no I'm trying to
Nicholas Cage
so so there's always a challenge he's
way too old at this point a lot of the
comments aren't questions typically and
so I'm trying to make sure I can get a
good question but that means scrolling
through and screening these you know
maybe maybe in a long term will uh we'll
find someone uh here's one that's a
question I'm confused by the temperature
of the room you were all in Andy's in a
scarf James with an open shirt look at a
long sleeve is your temperature
Equitable I don't know I think so
Andy's in a scarf because it looks very
jaunty and nice Snappy looking it's very
Snappy yeah I'm in a sweater because I'm
always cold here's here's a good
question beefy says Andy covering riots
when did you feel most scared
um
Tim's audience will remember this so in
May of last year I returned to Portland
uh which was a mistake but
I went back and uh I had less because it
was becoming very very dangerous to me
uh police were very overwhelmed in 2020
with the nightly violence and riots uh
the police were defunded and not a
record number of them had resigned and
took early uh retirement so they're just
the only calls that often they were
responding to were like priority calls
involving life or death situations so if
you have issues of a threatening person
showing up at your home you could take
hours for somebody to show up
and I knew all that but I went back
because field reporting is extremely
important and James and Tim you can
touch this because you did this when the
further you are away from the subject
that you covered you introduce more
errors right that's how you get these
journalists who are in Bureau desk rooms
in New York and DC who get things wrong
for example about the Russia hoax they
just depend on these uh these sources
right rather than being on the ground
and being able to verify things that had
been gone for a number of months and I
wanted to see how antifa's violence had
evolved towards the end of 2020 to the
many months to 2021 and I was there
undercover and observing and
unfortunately uh they became suspicious
because I wasn't riding with them
and they sent several feelers to come
and question me I write about this in
the update for my book on Mass
and uh one of them said I remember they
surrounded me I was alone they said uh I
think it's him
and even though I was in the middle of
downtown
two blocks away from the Central police
station I knew
I had no good options at the point what
do I do I start running what do I try
talking my way out you know my voice
I don't carry weapons
and uh well they assaulted me really
badly and uh
um that was
when they had me on the ground and
pinned on the ground and I could hear
more of them running after me and some
of them had their cameras out they were
like live streaming it trying to get
their comrades to come not all of them
have the intention to kill somebody but
we've seen in these mob settings it
takes one or two who are completely
unhinged and have nothing to lose to do
that kick to the head or the face right
I was so fortunate that I was able to
escape and run into that hotel and plead
with them
to lock the doors to call police and um
yeah I that whole entire experience has
been really traumatic and I remember
there was a big debate online afterwards
like and you know you waited and you
said why why why would you willingly
return to that situation
knowing one that you had been assaulted
before been under death threats and go
there complete without a good Escape
Plan I think that criticism was fair but
excuse me my my
first I think you know as many people
pointed out I was a little crass because
I was like on Twitter and I saw it and I
tweeted something like that was stupid
why would you do that and it's probably
a little crass but my my thought was you
know you wrote a book on antifa you're
you're beyond just going into a crowd of
these extremists and risking your life
when uh you're you're at the point where
I suppose I should say like your work is
too important the knowledge you have the
experience you have the connections
you've made the people you can connect
the information you have within you
would all be lost because you decided to
go out in that one night no I think it's
it's it's it's fair to say I mean it's
your responsibilities in this Regard in
your work they're your choice if you
think your work is best served doing
what you did then it's just opinion
versus opinion my attitude is you should
have three more you know people working
with you you should be doing what James
does James gets uh actually you came up
in this because many people pointed out
that you go through new undercover
reporters because if they get exposed
then you can't just keep using the same
people over and over again well we'd
you'd be surprised at how much a ball
cap and sunglasses can achieve but yeah
I mean they're
and there's a lot to say about that but
uh I admire Andy I I admire your your
fearlessness or your ability to overcome
your fear and go back there
yeah so that that was you know basically
it I mean on on my part probably crass
my initial reaction but I think the
point is we need you to keep doing your
work one of the reasons we're here today
talking about the work you've done and
the experiences you've had and the
threats you faced trying to cover
something that the media basically
covers up how do we make sure that like
the one journalist who knows how this
system is working is not going to end up
wiped off the map and that the work
you're doing expands into more
journalism I think it's great if the
media is going to report on Far Right
extremism wonderful absolutely but we
get all of that where are the reporters
who are going out and Reporting on far
left extremism it's few and far between
you're doing it Andy and we need more
people to be doing it so there's a fear
in like you would risk your life but we
need to get you to a point where you're
expanding and getting more people on the
ground you know what I mean
that's that's the gist of it but you
know other than that I mean I certainly
you know empathize with what you went
through I don't think I've never
experienced anything to that degree you
know I've certainly have have had antifa
get in my face but that was you know
considering what they did with the
milkshakes and the and attacking you and
you you know you were seriously you were
you were very seriously injured with
traumatic brain injury
and then experiencing that again I can
certainly you know empathize and say
it's a dangerous job man I'm glad you do
it though what does it say about America
though that in some urban areas areas of
the country you can't have journalists
or such as in journalists or even just
people regular people with the phones
out recording things that are happening
in public that you can just have moms or
violent extremists threatening violence
and doing it with impunity for years why
do you think that doesn't happen on the
right like like we have you know there's
right-wing extremists and stuff like
that why aren't they out there being
crazy and beating up I don't know they
they journalists and it exists but
there is um you know if we look at the
polling data independent voters lean
very heavily alongside conservatives in
in their opinions we did an event in the
Philadelphia area we had far left
journalists that we know lies show up
and we let them come in and knowing
they're going to lie we say okay do your
thing and they came in and lied and made
up crazy stories
well I wasn't I don't usually don't say
anybody's names but putting out these
stories where they claim that security
their security was at risk in a casino
that was just such a false hit I watched
that whole thing happen right we're in a
casino everything was fine the whole
time if you are a Jer see this is why we
were all there I remember that and this
is why you know we're strategic and how
we put on these events we had the event
in a casino why you're never going to
get better security I mean there's
there's so many cameras in casinos that
when the dealers are pulling out chips
they have to like move their hands out
of the way and do motion specifically
because everything is watched for
someone to come in and say my security
was threatened oh please you're in one
of the biggest most secure buildings in
the city but they but we let them come
anyway now what happens when Andy shows
up the truth as James pointed out scares
them they'll attack
I like to hear from the audience what
are they thinking let's try and find
some more uh some more Super chats
Morgan asks didn't Trump technically ban
speech at his rally I believe this is
over the fjb comment and the answer is
yes and it's important to call it out
and that also brings up you know a
weakness among you know individuals like
ourselves whatever fact you want to call
it Freedom good libertarian whatever is
that we have no problem being like Trump
shouldn't ban speech you can appreciate
the sentiment of course that you know
Trump's trying to be more cordial but on
the left they don't play that game they
do have their circular firing squads but
it seems like it's usually for
reinforcement of their of their uh of
wokism as opposed to any real principle
I think it's uh I think it's interesting
though and we've talked about this
before the idea that uh you know on the
left they're doing things a specific way
and so why are we trying to uphold a set
of standards and values that are not
being upheld on the other side this is
something James was talking about he's
clearly very committed to his standards
and his values he's not going to let
that be compromised
um and I think that's important you know
I think in times of Crisis and when your
values and when your standards are the
most threatened is when you need to
uphold them all the more yeah but you're
violating people's free speech that's
where a lot of people's issues comes up
saying hey why are you as an
Administration saying you can't say this
specifically All For You Know PR uh
images people people have branded me Tim
for years as this unethical criminal
scum lying deceptive editing they've
jailed me sued me they have not
physically attacked me knock on wood but
what's remarkable is I've written a book
with 800 footnotes law review articles
journalism ethics essays we wrestle and
struggle
with the ethics of what we do at project
Veritas so much so that we almost
torture ourselves about whether we
should publish and and if I was a
radical right-wing activist I would have
published Ashley Biden's diary I didn't
and that should be proof enough and and
the most important ethical rule for in
journalism is to behave like like there
are 12 jurors on your shoulder at all
times to not the whole point the whole
wrestling Detra of investigative
reporting is to expose that which others
want kept secret for the wrong reasons
so you have to behave like you have
nothing to keep secret and that's the
hardest part about I mean what we do
because it's often human nature that
wants to keep things secret the Rick
salabi story we did recently and I hope
you saw that one the CNN producer got
got uh the police got involved the
second producer man you want to hear us
a crazy quick anecdote
that CNN fired that guy salivi probably
within about 24 hours and didn't say a
word about it and two weeks went by yeah
and then in response to a tweet the vice
president of CNN getting Matt dornick
replied oh yeah he's gone that's old
news
what an incredible way to cover up so
that they wouldn't because if they said
immediately he was fired be Associated
Press bulletins yeah what an amazing
story that was I love when the criticism
accidentally exposes the machine when
they said that you go after left-wing
organizations and you had recently done
a story on Google and Facebook and then
it's like almost an admission of the
complaints people have about the
political bias these institutions to
claim that you're going after a
left-wing institution which happens to
be Google is kind of the media that's
always true you're going after you only
target the left well the New York Times
CNN
yeah the Department of Defense are these
left-wing organizations so your point is
the logic of that seems to presuppose
shows that they are left wing but the
left tends to as the the late Rush
Limbaugh once said told me as well the
the left tends to circle the wagons and
the right tends to circle the firing
squad and that's because of the
psychology of shame it all goes back it
all goes back to two to two principles
principle number one stop caring about
what they think of you
and and principle two always be hacked
like always behave like someone's
watching you
and if you do those two things I think
we'll be very successful as citizen
journalists
all right lots of compliments people
saying thank you James and Andy we have
Karen saying thank you James O'Keefe and
you know for being on the show and most
of all being actual journalists you are
so appreciated
we've got uh lesko saying Andy no and
James O'Keefe bravest men alive
oh yeah I would I would I would agree
we have uh let's find a good good uh
good question
North Viking says why do people on the
right care so much what the left thinks
perhaps finding that out will help us
free them to fight the left otherwise
just telling people to stop caring
probably isn't enough I do understand
why we say the left all the time and why
people say the left so often I think
um it's important to talk about
establishment Elites which have a
tendency to be today the establishment
left but uh what what do you got what do
you guys think we I think we talked
about this but why do you think the
right care so much about what they say
it's because the left has cultural
dominance
that matters a lot I don't think any
verse here would be honest if we said uh
if we just said I mean if the New York
Times was to write a nice profile about
one of us and we said oh well who cares
no I think each and one of us would care
we would like that sort of legitimacy
from the mainstream that like this paper
of record in America would I acknowledge
what we do I agree to an extent but I
also disagree I think a lot of people
would like that I'm not so sure the
people at this table for the most part
would be you know vying no I think I I
think to be fair to be fair to be clear
I sound like the 14th paragraph of the
New York Times article
to be fair it's unclear whether it's
amazing your NPR voice it's amazing I
know by NPR yeah
my reported voice yeah um Tim I think
all of us
in places we don't want to admit
want to be accepted you have to be a I
call it a masochist or a sociopath to
want to be hated we are all we all grew
up to be liked we want to be liked we
want to be loved I don't want to be
hated you don't I don't think you want
to be hated nothing that you do should
engender hatred
um
but
you have to kind of
fight against that evolutionary instinct
to to to suck up to the people who have
the cultural dominance right this I
think this is such an important I think
it's not so much for you know for me I
don't care if the New York Times wants
to write something nice about me I just
don't want them to lie yeah I appreciate
if people want they don't like me they
hate me they want to write about it and
say Here's why we hate them I'll be like
well you know people are entitled to
their to their hate I just I don't want
to be hated but more so I recognize I
will be I just don't want them to
publish lies it takes this kind of
indefatigable tunnel visioned obsession
in order to endure the hatred and the
pain because it does hurt and I'll be
honest it I mean it hurts it I remember
when I was 25 years old not 37 about 12
years ago I used to obsess about my
Wikipedia page I used to sit there and
like bite my nails obsessing and after a
while you just accept it you can't
change it and and and you and that
that's when you really grow I think
after that ordeal I think that it is
that leftist cultural dominance of you
know news organizations entertainment
and everything else that you guys are
talking about that that is is what makes
it so important that the outlets that
we're involved with continue to speak
out and to continue to speak the truth
Tim Cass does that project Veritas does
that post-millennial does that and we
need more Outlets like this we need more
venues for for this kind of conversation
and for you know an expression of
reality as opposed to this dogmatic
intolerance well we have a question here
from Vector tyrannus how do we as a
society reinstate journalistic integrity
and facts based news no narrative no
prefacing with your pet agenda just True
News how well I'll say become a member
at timcast.com because I'm I'm fairly
strict we've had people messages saying
like hey this article is poorly framed
and I'll immediately go in and be like
hey fix this we had one story where it
said Joe Biden criticized for doing X
and I went in and said change the
headline and story to Joe Biden does
acts and that include any relevant
commentary after the fact we don't I
don't want to do stories that are framed
negative or positive just tell people
what happened as for everybody else I
think supporting all of supporting the
work of everyone everyone here so I
don't know if you guys want to well I
would make a statement about the medium
of Journalism I think it came out in the
last couple weeks The Tick Tock has a
bigger audience than Google now so print
or the the written word account of
things the New York Times and these
organizations of propaganda rely upon
descriptions of things so I think doing
journalism that's visual uh doing
journalism that I mean television has
higher credibility than print for a
reason
um doing first-person observation
journalism uh uh reporting as an
observation firsthand observation is the
ultimate documentation that's what you
did in Portland do journalism where you
can see it where you don't have to trust
the reporter's depiction of the events
but you can see it with your own eyes
and ears I think that's a start and just
go ahead and go out and do it go out in
the field leave your you know your
apartment you know go there we go there
remember Vice used to work for vice
right Shane Smith's unique value
proposition in Times Square I saw a
billboard that said we go there imagine
how broken journalism must be when your
unique value proposition is to go to the
place you're reporting on it's kind of
wild yeah but it's like that evil and
wah novel scoop where he should like the
journalist shows up and to cover a war
and there is no war and all the
journalists who are there are like shh
don't tell anybody we're just kind of
making it up that's great yeah I don't
you guys want anything about what we can
do to save journalism
Andy
controversial view but um
I've been spending time in the UK and
the immediate landscape is very
different and in broadcast television
they actually have this a government
agency that enforces rules some
guidelines on partiality on broadcast
television and as a result
on their news channels you don't have
shows like that would future guess that
would for example just
make a statement let's say Donald Trump
is a fascist and a racist and then the
host just agrees you know you have to
have it for something like that the
responsibility is on the host to to
challenge you to ask for evidence or
they have a guess from an opposing
opinion uh that's not in the American
tradition but I think that's a result
then then I mean all of us have seen
some of these shows on MSNBC or some of
these equip right-wing equivalents and I
think it would violate the first
amendment I don't think we could do it
yeah I mean yeah I mean putting you know
the the the legal tradition Assad I just
mean culturally but oh for sure so I
haven't made up my mind quite about that
yet but I think I mean then in my view
the land the media landscape in the UK I
think is it's less uh insane than what
we have in America did you guys want
anything else to the that question
I think I think journalists need to ask
more questions instead of making
assumptions we see a lot of assumptions
in media uh especially on TV reporting
and I think that uh you know more
straightforward questions as opposed to
questions that lead with a narrative I
have this Meme here which I don't know
if you can see
it's a meme of what journalism used to
be the man is running towards the podium
asking questions and now the man is
running away from the podium with a
megaphone amplifying for the person so
my point I'm going to say is right into
the camera
journalists do your jobs
do your job it's real it's real simple
like you just said ask questions don't
trust what they tell you bite the hand
that feeds you bite the hands that feeds
you that's what we do at project and
stop editorialism I don't care about
what you think I don't want to know what
you think
I want to know I want to see it with my
own eyes or I don't trust it people say
where do you get your information from
from actual evidence
documents from the defense department
and so that's what I love about when
they smear you as conspiracy theorists
I'm like when James O'Keefe publishes a
video of a person at a company saying
something where's the conspiracy like I
don't report anything that you actually
see their lips moving like I need to see
the face of the person and the other
thing I'll say is because you know
people say well some people won't like
it well if there's one person who will
listen tell the truth there's a point in
this book where I was at my nadir in my
life where I thought about quitting and
my own mother and sister said well if
there's a one person
that will listen to your journalism then
it's worth doing
and that's how low I had to go after my
Ascent to the highest peak I was down
again and up and down and and now our
audience has grown although you have a
gold plaque for your million subscribers
Google has not said that to me to be
fair James I'm using one of them as a
window
open you have two of them and oh we've
got like yeah I got a bunch of them they
haven't sent that to us yet we actually
they actually they accidentally sent me
two for one of my channels no yeah
you're using it as a door stopper so the
window won't stay open so we jammed the
the golden aboard you know one thing I
just want to respond to what you were
saying because what you're saying about
the megaphone where the the journalist
is now amplifying the message what
happened to question authority right
this used to be a pretty standard idea
in America that we would question
authority and now the new definition of
domestic terrorism and domestic
extremism is someone who is
anti-government and anti-authority and
what the hell is that yeah and just
really quick I also wanted to say uh
we're all journalists if you see an
injustice speak up don't be afraid to
say in anything to tweet it to get it
out there to the general public because
it's us all willing to participate and
speak out against injustices that could
actually stop it I used to doorstep a
lot of politicians and I think I almost
said exactly what you were saying as I
was being dragged out from a Larry
Silverstein uh press conference ask
questions demand answers and of course
your jobs do your dude shut up please
they're not they're not going to do it
you will as an independent journalist as
just an average civilian you have the
power in your hands to broadcast and to
shed light on the darkest corners of
this world to do it I got it I just
figured it out imagine you have every
plumber in the country has stopped
fixing Plumbing and our bathrooms and
our streets are laid in with crap
and there's one guy there's a small
handful of people that are actually
trying to get the plumbing working again
that crap that analogy is what's
happening in our political space is
what's happening with our big
institutions because journalists stopped
fixing the pipes they stopped doing
their jobs and they've just let the crap
flow flow free we need people to
actually do the work and fix it so we
can flush this crap I view it as an
opportunity
if you people need to be brave here's my
NPR voice
be brave do something Veritas tips at
protonmail.com and American muckraker is
the book and all of the proceeds go to
our non-profit organization which funds
our journalism salaries but I think you
go there like Andy noted go there
go go on location do the job they they
refuse to do and expose them we got tear
gas together in Greece we did get tears
no we went there as well and what do we
do put milk in our eyes I forgot there's
some kind of solution that we got it was
just some some random person came up to
us there's like hey just put this in
your eyebrow I'm producing you know we
we do all this reporting I produce it
and Luke here just streams it on
Snapchat or something I was Snapchatting
back then uh Snapchat doing like small
stories and the Snippets as we were
covering extreme civil unrest in Greece
literally as there was molotovs being
thrown at police officers and in Crazy
battles in the streets of Athens Greece
that were uh absolutely crazy during
their uh what was it there they banned
people from taking money out of their
bank accounts yeah there was a yeah and
there was one anecdote you're in Greece
and I was holding a camcorder in 2015
this is the time with the economic
crisis and this Greek guy saw me with
the camcorder and these were literal
Communists they had a communist flag and
they started marching toward me and the
other I said no no and in an accent he
said no he's an American and he stopped
from assaulting me yeah it's a very
powerful moment don't assault the
American why do you think that was
it's pretty Dr yeah that's probably it
is my friend was also there he got put
in the hospital because activists beat
the crap out of him as he was reporting
on the front lines because he took the
camera and he put it on the people that
were throwing rocks against the police I
mean we're this is America damn it you
know this is America and
I don't think we're going to become like
these other countries I don't think we
can I think the power of one is too big
here the courage is
courage is too contagious here I've seen
it with my own eyes I have sources right
now inside the justice department I will
say it on the record I was here last
time I was talking to Christopher Ray
directly in the camera I got rated a few
months later so I don't know what's
going to happen but I've got sources
inside the justice department I want
that story okay I want to see it it's
too the courage is too courageous too
exciting it's too much fun it's it's fun
speaking truth to power isn't it
absolutely there's great joy in fighting
it's so much more fun than the
alternative yeah and the other thing too
is like when our you know when our
culture is big enough the dominance of
the left will decrease
I mean Andrew bipart used to say the day
days before he died Andrew Piper said to
me James they want us on a leash we're
not going to be on a leash they want us
to dance
we refuse to dance with them
politics will eventually be replaced by
imagery
and um
I think people just have to have the
courage they just got out of the courage
to step up all right let me read this
one here we got uh armino the Pug says
question for everyone at our current
rate do you think that civil unrest and
conflict is unavoidable is there a
possibility of someone embodying the
American Spirit to bridge The Divide we
face
what was that last part someone
embodying the yeah the American Spirit
that can Bridge The Divide interesting
I'm a bit less pessimistic on any kind
of you know unification between culture
War factions but what do you guys think
Jeffrey Epstein perhaps but but maybe a
more positive thing no no no he brings
together the left and the right against
people's condemnation against the the
state that abuses their power and used
taxpayers to hurt children for over 30
years in unspeakable ways that's a
bridge right there that's a gap that the
establishment is scared of since people
on the left and right are tweet tweeting
very important aspects of this story
that break down this whole entire
structure's power
putting putting journalists in handcuffs
brain left and right indicting me for
excessive that's true if they indict me
for accessory after the fact for a
source sending me documents that'll
bring left and right together and it's
probably a self-preservation because
they don't want it to happen to them
yeah but what about you Andy you know
being on the ground and seeing a lot of
this extremism do you think there's a
possibility of uniting people in this
country
uh I thought that the the beating
assault of uh a journalists of color
who's hoping to be gay uh that was
caught on camera I thought that would be
kind of a unifying moment and uh it
wasn't there was a lot of people on the
mainstream left who
uh so essentially that I deserved that I
was such an agitator or that I allegedly
hold such deplorable views on what
happened to me was deserving and just
and I should it should happen again it
should happen every time I come out so
uh I I'm a bit less optimistic of my uh
of the American citizenry I think in
general I think what's been very clear
since the death of George Floyd and
going back and forth after Michael Brown
has just been this uh
noticeable shift in moral tolerance and
political violence and if uh I mean you
cross this line you know of accepting
violence as a response to disagreement
and that's how you that's how you break
down civilization and societies and
eventually the state
man it's a little dark I think we're
good yeah I think we're a little far
from a unifying moment as well or any
kind of
unifying figure we're seeing
conservative culture start
being on a parallel track right creating
its own ecosystem
um and I think that's going to continue
you know like I was just talking to a
woman Sarah Gonzalez who has a podcast
and she started a makeup line that's
essentially like a conservative makeup
line it's made in the U.S and I was like
that's interesting because I've been
talking to people who were starting you
know I talked to Jason Miller who
started his own uh conservative
basically based social media platform
there's conservative journalism and now
we're going to have a conservative
makeup line it kind of reminded me of
when Christian Soriano found out that no
one would sign a dress for Melania to
wear to the inauguration and he was like
I'll do it you know like we're gonna see
I think more of that as opposed to less
of that going forward I agree and if
you're listening now smash that like
button subscribe to this channel go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only podcast coming up we
post them around 11 or so p.m so make
sure you hit that you can follow the
show at timcast IRL follow us on
Instagram if you want Clips you can
follow me at timcast do you guys want to
shout out what you got going on with
James
I mean the book is
americanmuckraker.com
americanmuscricket.com you can buy the
book at americanmerica.com or you can go
on Amazon if you want to support Jeff
Bezos
um but uh the book is really a a seminal
work of non-fiction recounts the
journalistic mass movements of today
eye-opening glimpse into gorilla
journalism there's a part about Andy
know in this book chapter one suffering
and David deliden
um I mean my closing argument is
essentially the image images
images transfix I think images the the
you know Marshall mccluen once said
something to the effect of images will
become more powerful than our own
politicians government is broken
the solution rests with us and this is a
how-to guide and how to do journalism in
clown World in clown world you need a
handbook like the Boy Scout Handbook
this is what this is for citizen
journalists right Andy
uh my updated book unmasked inside
antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy is coming out uh on the 1st of
February in an updated version and
paperback so that's available for
pre-order now and uh I encourage if
people like my work to to become
supporter at uh ngo.locals.com
right on thank you Libby I think
everyone should come to the post
millennial read the work that we've got
up uh you can subscribe to the post
millennial you can donate and help us
out the postmillennial.com donations and
I'm there every day I'm on Twitter at
Libya men's sweet so I'm somewhat close
to 1 million subscribers on youtube.com
forward slash we are change which I
release videos on routinely and uh
before we leave shouts out to Dana White
he dropped some major truth bombs today
I actually talked about that on my Luke
uncensored.com video hope to see some of
you guys there I've been working really
hard lately and uh I can't thank you
guys for all coming and being in the
same room it was a great productive
conversation thank you guys for uh
putting it uh all together also Tim
project Veritas experience.com we're
having a book launch event in Miami
January 29th project
veritasexperience.com if you want to go
awesome I was going to say to two if you
guys do end up using Amazon you can
donate to project Veritas that's true
Amazon smile I believe that's what it's
called that's what I use I thought that
was a great finger in the eye of Amazon
when I saw that and I decided to sign up
for it it's awesome anyway you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch let's
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in about an hour thanks for hanging out
we'll see you there bye guys